thank you it's a pleasure
to be here good evening albert einstein
once said that there were only two
things that
might be infinite the universe and
human stupidity and he followed it by
saying
that he had no confidence that the
universe
was infinite now
when we hear that you know we chuckle
or at least we smile but what we don't
do is
nobody feels insulted by that no one
takes offense at it and the reason
of course is that when we hear those
words right we see albert einstein right
we see
that warm hearted that good
natured of vungular sage from an earlier
era right we
we see the the wild hair starry-eyed
genius right whose iconic imagery
from from riding a bicycle to
sticking out his tongue to being lost
in pensive thought all of this imagery
is
emblazoned in our collective
cultural memory and einstein's
story right at least the version that we
tell when we re-tell
right of the the the young
boy who could barely talk
until he was three four or five or the
the young
student who failed at school or the
young brash graduate who gets shipped
off to the patent office
i mean this is stuff of myth making and
then
the storm of creative thought
that flows forward that launches
quantum mechanics the special theory of
relativity the general theory
of relativity completely rewriting our
understanding of space and time and
matter and energy i mean
as a physicist i have studied these
ideas
intently i've taught them i've i've
spent decades with
colleagues trying to push these ideas
forward
and i have to tell you that they never
lose their wonder i mean i am
as amazed today regarding what
einstein found as i was when i first
encountered these ideas 30
40 years ago so
how did he do it
right is it personality is it
perspiration is it some potent
mix of brain physiology together with
the particular scientific moment when he
came on the scene is it all of it i mean
what
was happening in einstein's life when he
was putting forward
all of these amazing ideas
and how have his discovery stood up to
the test
of time well these are some of the
questions
that we are going to be exploring here
tonight in tonight's program a program
that
we at the world science festival are
proud to co-present with the 92nd street
why
and we are honored that tonight's
discussion
will be led by the senior legal and
investigative correspondent at nbc news
the former anchor of abc news nightline
two-time
emmy award winner so please join me
in bringing to the stage cynthia
mcfadden
great to see you
i i feel that we should have full
disclosure i come here as a journalist
which someone once
said was just the little kid on the
street who wanted to be the first one to
run down the street and say guess what i
know
well tonight i don't know very much i
want to disclose that i had to drop
out in college i had to drop out of the
class
poet physics for poets okay i couldn't
handle it so i hope i'm going to learn a
lot tonight
i certainly have a lot of questions
brian it's always great to be with you
and welcome to all of you to the genius
of einstein
i want to start with a quote a quote
from professor einstein
here's what he said i want to know how
god created the world
i'm not interested in this or that
phenomenon in the spectrum of
this or that element i want to know his
thoughts the rest are details
so tonight we're going to explore the
genius of einstein from three
perspectives who he was as a human being
what he scientifically gave to the world
and also what neuroscience may tell us
about the man's brain
we brought together three people who
have spent a great deal of time thinking
about these things you've already met
brian greene to talk about einstein the
man
i'd like to introduce author filmmaker
and professor of science writing at mit
he has produced more than a dozen
science documentaries and written five
books including newton and the
counterfeiter
and einstein in berlin please welcome
thomas levinson
great to have you also joining us is
professor of neurology and ophthalmology
at robert wood johnson medical school of
rutgers university his research areas
have ranged from abnormal eye movements
to the very brain of albert einstein so
please join me in welcoming dr
frederick lapore doctor
hi so let's get right into it
let's start with the year 1905. it was
known as einstein's
anna's mirabilis his miracle year brian
lead us off
yeah now that was uh an amazing
period of intellectual fervor it's hard
to
compare it it's hard to even imagine
that
kind of scientific outpouring
happening so einstein wrote many papers
in that year four of them were
absolutely
astounding one of them did launch
quantum mechanics
one of them established the existence of
atoms
and the two that i think have captured
our imagination more than any other were
his papers to do with the special theory
of relativity we're going to get into
that more deeply as we go but what was i
mean to have this kind of a creative
period what was going on in the rest of
his lifetime at that time
well einstein in 1905 was in some ways
um really disadvantaged and in some ways
i think he himself would have said he
had this
great opportunity he was disadvantaged
because for a variety of reasons he
completely
you know failed to get the kind of
university job or
uh really entry into graduate school as
it was then not quite the way we do it
now
after he finished his physics degree at
uh switzerland's leading
technical institution the the the
polytechnic in zurich
he just he alienated his professors he
didn't bother paying attention to things
he wasn't
interested in all that you know the kind
of student you would expect einstein to
be
so he didn't get any help from him when
he graduated and he was in the
wilderness he taught
algebra to to uh high school students
for a while
that must have gone really well can you
imagine being can you imagine einstein's
you know saying i i couldn't figure out
a quadratic equation under einstein's
very embarrassing um so he's
disadvantaged on the other hand
he got this job in the patent office
where he was looking at technical
material all the time
he was learning to visualize physical
physical situations and he had
um partly because he didn't really he
wasn't really a great family man he
spent really a lot of time
even though he's married and had a young
son he had
great freedom to just think and i
believe that that
one of the things you see in einstein
after he gets a patent office job
and really starts settling into being a
sort of grown-up
um he really starts developing the
characteristic you would have for the
rest of his life which was this
extraordinary ability to focus no matter
what was going on around him
would it be fair to say that his life
was chaotic and that in his scientific
life he was looking for more order
i think it's certainly true and einstein
himself wrote this in in what he called
his autobiographical note many years
later
it's certainly true that einstein saw in
science and escape from these are his
words
the merely personal there was this great
territory out there
i don't think his life was terribly
chaotic in 1905 i think he was a
solid you know young bourgeois swiss
citizen
going to his job every day small child
taking hikes in the hills with his
friends
it was you know einstein the young man
was not the bohemian eccentric genius
we later you know as brian was saying we
had this image of einstein
einstein at 25 26 was a guy who
went to his job and worked on his hobby
in his spare time and his hobby turned
out to be revolutionizing
the world of physics hey
he did love to play the violin and and
fred one of the things that
what that you've learned in looking at
his brain is is you can you can
understand
some you can tell us what we can
understand by looking at his brain
let's go there he was a gifted musician
and he he loved to play the violin love
to play
duets and um again
dean faulk who's the person who did the
anatomy and a couple of papers who i
collaborated with
he has a finding of a kind of a we'll
show a picture of it later
but uh it looks like a knob it looks
like an omega sign an elaboration of his
motor cortex
on the right side and for somebody who's
fingering with his left hand we now know
mostly from neuroimaging that there are
a lot of musicians
who do have this kind of elaboration in
their cortex
that you see with people who are
left-handed string
so does the knob predate being a
musician or does being a
musician create the knob that's a great
question we don't know
we don't know you know come on you're a
scientist you're supposed to know this
stuff
well you'd have to come up with a serial
neuroimaging
uh for pure research purposes you know
start with a six-year-old and
yeah it's a great no one's done that i
mean that seems like a scientific
experiment you can do no
you need the funding you need the
funding i i mean i hate to say
he's gonna be outside afterwards yeah
you know you say listen i want to pitch
this idea do six-year-olds with cortical
knobs become
violin prodigies uh you may be able to
do that or do prodigies but develop a
knob and it may be a little bit of both
i mean i think if anything's
changed in in my lifetime in the
conception of neuroscience is plasticity
that you can enhance your wiring by
learning experiences
so the question is if you spend that ten
thousand hours or whatever
uh developing a skill with your left
hand could you
actually see tangible changes on the
surface of the cortex
don't know for sure all we know is he
had the cortical knob
on the right of his brain okay so now i
take a deep breath
and i say to you brian explain what
special relativity is
this is easy for you and hard for me yes
so
you know it's a funny thing because
special relativity
is one of the most simple ideas
mathematically it only uses high school
algebra
but it is one of the deepest conceptual
breaks so it's hard for all of us
to to grasp these ideas so
roughly speaking around the year 1905 a
few years before
there was a lot of discussion and
confusion having to do with light
and its speed and the question was
could the speed of light depend upon
the source that's emitting the light and
could it depend upon
the motion of the person receiving it
right so if i was to take this
this coffee cup and throw it toward you
at say three miles an hour
i won't actually that's just the thought
of gdonkin experiment as einstein called
it right
so i throw it at you three miles an hour
you'll receive it at that speed
it's obvious that if you run toward me
the cup is going to appear
to approach you from your perspective
more quickly and if you run away from it
it'll approach you less quickly and that
is basic
intuition about how motion works but as
it
turned out with light it seemed that
that was not the case
if i fire a laser beam at you
it'll approach you at 186 000 miles per
second regardless of whether you're
sitting still running toward me or going
away
now at the time many people were not
ready to accept that kind of idea they
were
coming up with all sorts of contorted
notions to try to sidestep
that but einstein was the kind of
thinker who would just come out
see the facts very clearly and throw
away
the preconceived notions and say look
that is what is the case the speed of
light is constant
and you just need to accept that the
problem is if you think about it
if the speed of light is constant that
means it's behaving weirdly
relative to experience and speed what is
speed well it's how far something goes
divided by how long it takes to get
there
so it's space over time so if speed
behaves weirdly then space
and time are behaving weirdly and
einstein went for it and figured out how
weirdly they behaved that's what he
worked out in special relativity
raise your hand if you could repeat that
i don't know if i could repeat that so
so it's the relationship between spaces
yes
exactly he finds that there's this kind
of dance
that space and time engage in where
they go back and forth between each
other in order to keep the speed of
light constant
and he makes that idea precise and
mathematical so
if you want to figure out and have a
sense of how
this notion of constant light speed
affects time
we'd love to use this little example
here it's called a light clock
this is really just like a wrist watch
it goes tick tock
tick tock it's a way of measuring
elapsed time where we can see the
internal mechanism of the clock
you can use any clock that you like but
they aren't as
transparent as this one and for our
purposes you can use this to
pretty quickly get to einstein's
conclusion
which is time slows down when a clock
is in motion now if you want i can show
you that but i leave it up to you
if you want to see it i say yes yes all
right so one piece of you're not going
to throw the cup at me no the cupcake
well i may throw it at you okay not yet
okay but um
so so what we want to do is now take two
of these light clocks
and we want one of them to move relative
to the other
so the one on the right will set it into
motion here's the thing look at the
trajectory
of that ball of light it's going on a
double diagonal trajectory compared to
the straight up and down trajectory
of the clock on the left-hand side now
if the speed of light is constant
and yet for it to go tick-tock in the
moving clock
it has to go further because that double
diagonal is longer
look at time on the moving clock
compared to the station if you could
actually run that one again so you can
just sort of see it in action
watch the counter on the moving clock
compared to the stationary
and you'll see that time is elapsing
more slowly
simply because the speed of light is
constant but the ball has to go further
in the moving clock to accomplish tick
tock
tick tock longer trajectory same speed
it will go tick-tock less quickly time
slows down
that little demonstration einstein
made mathematical again it's high school
algebra
and that transforms our understanding of
time before that everybody
thought from newton that there's a
universal clock
out there that ticks off time second
after second after second
it drags us all forward in time at
exactly the same rate regardless of what
we do
regardless of how we are moving but
einstein shows that if i get up and
start to walk
my clock compared to yours if you look
at it will tick off time more slowly
more slowly time is not universal
time is in the eye of the beholder and
depends upon
the beholder's motion that's crazy
but true was this the beginning of
quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is a different story
that we could get into
but that reaction is perfect in 1905
he did this yeah and he did the first
paper wrote the first paper on quantum
mechanics and they're completely
separate
lay it on us it's crazy well yeah
quantum mechanics is a whole different
story and just you know
in two sentences it's a theory that
applies to the micro world
and starts with einstein's paper go
through a lot of development but
ultimately it gets to a place where we
learn from the quantum law that you
can't predict
definite outcomes in any experiment you
can only predict the probability
of one outcome or another you can
predict an electron will be here with 30
percent likelihood 20 percent likelihood
here 50
over here that's a completely different
perspective of reality compared
again to the one that newton gave us
newton says tell me how things are
and i'll use my math to predict how they
will be in the future
and quantum theory says that's the wrong
way of thinking about it all you can do
is predict the likelihood of one outcome
or
another again a completely crazy set of
ideas that are borne out by experiment
and yes you follow the intellectual
trail of quantum theory
and smacks right back into einstein's
1905 paper
which is the one for which he got the
nobel prize tom
so just a couple things to as grace
notes to what brian said
first of all the the the paper he's he's
skipped over a little bit
on the on the uh existence and
dimensions of atoms and molecules
is of the 1905 papers the most cited
and the reason is it has the most direct
uh practical applications it applies to
such
children's questions as why is the sky
blue which actually einstein answered in
another paper in 1910
but it's also used for doing things like
working out the mathematics of mixing
paint
so this paper that often doesn't get
discussed
in in sort of you know because
especially because relativity and
quantum mechanics are so important
uh was itself you know this this amazing
result
um but the other thing i just want to
say is that um
brian said that one of einstein's gifts
as a genius was the ability to look at
facts
for what they are and follow them where
they led
even if they upset um preconceptions
that einstein himself may have had
and this was true actually even within
the the quantum theory i mean it's
famous that
einstein uh really didn't like quantum
mechanics in its
in its fully developed form but he
didn't stop doing
quantum theory in 1905 he kept doing
major contributions to the quantum
theory for another two decades
and he even did the first papers that
really looked
at the fact that in the micro world
you would have an essential irreducible
element of randomness he published this
this stuff in first started publishing
in 1916-17
and he wrote a letter to a a colleague i
think it was max born a close friend and
a great physicist nobel prize-winning
physicist
in his own right and said you know i
wouldn't want to give up causality
but there it is um and so when you think
about einstein uh
in his in his um just the kind
of mind he was and the kind of uh sort
of
attributes that made him so powerful a
thinker
on the one hand it's his ability to
follow to
see facts for what they are consider
their implications and follow them where
they will
and it's notable that this wasn't in
some senses an
infinite resource he was able to do it
with the quantum theory for a very long
time and he reached a point
where not just because he was getting
older and less flexible
though that was part of it but because
in some sense
he was also prone to thinking about
things that were congenial to him he had
taste in physics he had things that he
liked he had
ideas he responded to more than others
and there was a point at which physics
moved away from the center of his
affections
but before it did that and even i mean
even after he was still an incredibly
formidable thinker but before he did
that he was just
astonishing i want to come back to the
brain
in just a second but first let's go to
berlin
1914 almost a decade after
these amazing papers come out uh
the politics and the circumstances
surrounding einstein's life at that time
let's let's talk a little bit brian
about how these circumstances affected
his thinking and
his productivity as a scientist well i
think
tom can probably speak more to the
surrounding
influences but berlin
was the time when
he is hot on the trail of the general
theory of relativity he spent some time
in
prague moved back to zurich and then
finally goes to berlin i think it was
1914 spring of 1914 he goes to berlin
and he started to really think about
general relativity back in zurich in
1912
and makes some headway toward the
the general theory of relativity but
it's in berlin
that it really starts to all come
together
and by 1915 november 19 we're in the
100th anniversary of
that momentous month he
gives four lectures at the prussian
academy of science where week after week
after week he's getting closer and
closer and closer
and finally november 25th he writes down
the field equations of the general
theory of relativity
so tom set the picture for us i mean he
is being wooed to berlin despite the
fact that he's jewish well
this is 1914 i mean one of the things
just as brian said at the beginning you
know we have this image of einstein at
the end of his life and we
sort of pushed that back to the
beginning we have this image of germany
in the 20th century
and you know the germany of uh the
post-world war one period and then the
hitler period is
very very different from the the last
days of imperial germany which is what
you what you have before
before the start of the war so yeah
there was anti-semitism all over europe
but it was
you know genteel anti-semitism
and for einstein it really wasn't much
of a
you know it just didn't it didn't really
register on him yet
um he was wooed to berlin
in what was really a bargain i mean
einstein saw it that way
he was clearly one of the strongest if
not
the already the preeminent theoretical
physicist in europe
and berlin germany in general in berlin
was the center of european
science it was and certainly for physics
i mean it was an amazing collection of
people who were working in the prussian
academy in the various
institutes so berlin said we want you to
add luster to our establishment and
um we will bring you there with no
teaching responsibilities a great salary
your own institute
you know support for things that you
might like like an expedition to test
your
your evolving theory of gravity um once
you come and he said fine
even though among other things his wife
really hated the idea
uh it was you know
look the idea of institutions wooing
star
academics is not exactly a foreign one i
mean it does
occasionally happen in this day and age
so and that's really what happened and i
think einstein had no thought of
politics at that time
i mean it's it's hard to recall how
implausible
world war one was up until you know
days before the declarations of wars
were
working he certainly became political oh
he became political because of the war
not
not beforehand it was and it was
explicitly the reaction of his fellow
german scientists to the outbreak of
world war one that first triggered his
political instincts
there was a famous manifesto of 93 which
93 leading german intellectuals
signed this document that said germany
is not to blame for the war we're
we are bringing the bringing
civilization
we aren't as bad as the english and
french who are lying with
mongols and slavs i mean uh
it was it was really horrific and it was
a it was
again with hindsight it looks oh of
course they would do that it's how
german
but to einstein it was a complete
surprise
that his cultured you know
literate poetry quoting physics
colleagues would join in this manifesto
and and that they would express such
nationalism
when again science was his retreat from
the merely personal science was
something that was international or
supranational he hated that
and he became political almost from the
you know first moments of the war
so in this stew out comes
the general theory of general relativity
go yeah yeah no exactly you know and it
really was
the result in a sense of almost
10 full years of struggle to try to
figure out
the force of gravity that's what the
general theory of relativity is all
about and it's a
it's a funny thing to think about
because
almost none of us today
could even imagine spending 10 years on
a single
problem i mean you try to go back to get
your grant renewed when you haven't
got any progress on this problem that
you set for yourself
and it's not gonna go particularly well
i mean
you know if i'm just like i'm putting in
a grant proposal and getting rejected
you know and this is the kind of thing
that at least today would happen
so he had an amazing capacity to stay
with a problem and this issue of how
does gravity work that's really the
issue that's driving him
right is is one that he spends
10 years on and finally not only comes
to
a beautiful answer but it comes to a
beautiful mathematical encapsulation
of that answer so what is the answer
well you know we all know that newton
basically said that you have
the sun you have the earth and there's
this force of gravity that keeps the
earth in orbit
but einstein is well aware and newton
was too that newton's
never told anybody how that force is
communicated
so einstein looks at this situation as
others could have done for 200 years
nothing changed
again he just looked at the same thing
that everybody else looked at
and so what do you have you got the sun
you have the earth what's between them
space so it's got to be that space
somehow
is the thing that communicates the force
of gravity so this little picture
gives a sense of what that is so here's
3d space
and einstein's idea is that space is
uncurved it's kind of flat
if there's no matter or energy but if
you bring in a body like the sun
einstein tells us that the fabric of
space in fact space-time curves
and it's that curvature that keeps
objects in orbit so look at the moon
around the earth
the earth is warping the environment and
the moon is kept in orbit
kind of because space is nudging it
around
keeping it rolling along this valley in
this curved environment and if you
if you pull back from this imagery you
see that the earth is kept in orbit
for exactly the same reason that is what
einstein says is how
gravity works and he didn't even have
graphics think about it yeah i know how
did he even
ever how did he do his public lectures i
don't know uh
but um true and the and the wonderful
thing is
there is a mathematical version of this
which again this is the part that's
harder to communicate
if you don't study mathematics but when
we look at that equation
i wish we had i don't think we have it
but you know it's this beautiful little
equation
r mu nu minus a half g meanwhile because
a pi g over c to the fourth team is
beautiful little look
come on there you go you can you give it
back to us and
when we look at it it's one of the most
amazing
compact formulae that describes
gravity in terms of warps and curves the
geometry of space and time
so many people look at this moment
in november of 1915 as
the pinnacle moment in einstein's
scientific career how can we know it's
true
how can we know it's true yeah it's a
good question uh and for einstein we can
answer it for more modern things it's
harder
but um for einstein he realizes that
there are a number of ways that you
could test this the first is
in in november of 1915
before uh you can hold off on this for a
second he realizes that there's a puzzle
which i believe you just wrote a book
about
and the puzzle is having to do with the
motion of the planet mercury
so people have known for a long time
that mercury's orbit wasn't closing on
itself the way newtonian physics said
that it should it was
shifting by a little bit 43 arc seconds
per century a little tiny shift and no
one could figure out why some suggested
maybe there was another planet called
vulcan
that was out there pulling on the
motion of mercury and you have a
beautiful book that's going to come out
and tell people all about this
but einstein says that doesn't make much
sense to me
let me recalculate mercury's motion
using my new equations
sits down does the calculation and by
his own account
when he looked at the result he had
heart palpitations that lasted for hours
because the math showed the same answer
that the observers had
so that was a real key moment for
einstein in fact there's a quota
maybe you know what it is but he says
something like something snapped inside
of me
that was the moment when he knew that he
had looked into reality in a way that
nobody
previously had but a real test
is not too retro it's not to retrodict
it's to predict something that no one
has
seen before and that's where this
wonderful little document that i think
you brought to
our attention i never saw this before
it's a beautiful can you bring that back
up the
that that note maybe not
there it is so so i mean you want to
describe this
sure this is einstein went through
this enormous struggle to get to general
relativity um
and uh i will defer to brian to tell me
if this is true but basically
uh as of 1913 he he
got some help with the math that was uh
his his mathematician friend told him
was too deep and too hard for physicists
um grossman talked about it yeah you're
the riemann tensor
he said physicists stay away from it
exactly and that led einstein to look at
it of course it was perfect
and uh and they worked out this this
amazing theory that had
um uh matter and energy warping
um space and time except
it wasn't they was warping he knew that
time warped under
gravitation that point but he wasn't
sure about space yet
and but he knew even at that stage of
the theory that if
you saw gravitation as um
as matter-deforming space-time
then anything that travels through
space-time including light itself would
have to be
would be deflected in the presence of a
big uh big gravitational field a big
dent in space-time
and that's what he's drawing here and
what this letter is about he's is in
1913 he's figured this out
he's got a number it's the wrong number
it turns out he's going to work it out
later
um but he's sending a note to the
american solar astronomer
george ellery hale who among other
things
built the biggest american telescope
biggest telescopes in the world for
about 30 years um but hale was himself
not a deep space astronomer but a solar
astronomer and
um einstein wanted to know if there was
any way at all
that you could actually test this out in
daylight
and the answer was hail regretfully
reported no
but it turns out that you can take this
idea
further which einstein did later on
and realized that during a solar eclipse
when the moon
obscures the sun you can see the distant
stars and according to these ideas of
general relativity
the distant star light should travel on
a curved trajectory on its way
to the earth being moved deflected
by the sun and that would therefore
shift the star's apparent position in
the sky
so if during a solar eclipse you could
take photographs of the background stars
and compare their positions to where
they appeared
six months earlier when the sun was on
the other side of the earth and having
no
influence on the trajectory of the
starlight a tiny
shift would be apparent if einstein's
ideas are
correct it's a little tiny angular
difference but einstein could calculate
what it would be so that's the proof
well that's the
proposal then you got to go out and do
the measurement and the measurements
were undertaken in 1919
two teams went out to uh brazil and
off the west coast of africa and they
took these photographs as best they
could there are various technical
problems with weather and so forth but
ultimately by september of 1919
the data was analyzed and the folks
doing the analysis were convinced that
the data established einstein's theory
and they they sent einstein a telegram
and einstein
sees that the result is positive and
he's with the student
at the time when the telegram comes ilsa
schneider and she says to him
what will you have said professor
einstein if the results had not agreed
with the general theory of relativity
einstein famously says i would have been
sorry for the dear lord because the
theory is correct
like how he thinks so he
was arguably the most famous and is
still arguably the most famous scientist
one of the most famous men to have ever
lived and it's not a very high bar we
should say
but uh yes it is no it's uh
so i'm interested in how he saw himself
at that point and
and i'm interested in his brain i mean
it's it's worth noting that einstein
actually
had his own brain had an e-e-g
ekg done of his brain eeg done in his
brain i i mean it's hard to translate
the anatomy into the guy's personality
but
the guy was saintly he had uh in the
sense that he was very
self-effacing i mean again and again
he had this incredible reputation but
he was not a hard bargainer when he came
to the united states to work at the
institute for advanced study
and you know i think at the end if you
want to bring it back to the brain
um one of the you know he was cremated
and i think one of the reasons he was
cremated was he was concerned that their
people would want artifacts of a saint
and he was right
um at the time of his autopsy um forget
about the brain
his eyes were removed by his
ophthalmologist and they've never been
seen again
and he he was this was his own
ophthalmologist and uh he was dead on
that i'm
glad we don't have that picture yeah
yeah i don't have a picture of that one
sorry but um you know he was a a very
modest kind of a guy who lived in a
world of ideas
and yet by the time he comes back to
america many people talk about these
next 30 years as the lost
years and i'm fascinated by that a man
with this
enormous brain who has these thoughts
that are unimaginable for most of us
that that are even proved some of them
some of them well maybe not yet he never
made his peace with quantum mechanics he
never made his peace with it
but but what about those years when he
finally he gets lord to princeton
so tell us about that well
he um he became you know from
from his start in anti-war politics in
germany during the
the great war the so the great war um
you know he went on to develop a much
broader and i think
uh more more generally humanistic uh
set of politics and he was an acute
observer of what was going on in germany
uh you know he including threats to
himself
personally i mean he once said that he
didn't know it was jewish until his
german enemies taught him that's a
paraphrase but it was pretty close to
that
um and so he was he was attentive
to the rise of hitler at first like most
sane thinking people um he thought
hitler didn't have staying power he said
you know hitler's risen to
to power again a paraphrase on the
stomachs on the empty stomachs the the
german people and and you know
when things get better he'll disappear
but by the 3132 it was very clear to him
that this was that hitler was a deep and
immediate danger
to germany and to jews in germany in
particular
and that it might not be tenable for him
to stay and at that point he had already
a deal with caltech to do a one semester
year for three years of visiting
professorship
and she was coming to america every year
and
um i think you know by night by middle
of 1932 it was
he was thinking that he might not come
back from
his next visit to caltech and it was in
that circumstance
that uh flexner the the
magnate who the the imp the intellectual
impresario who
set up the institute for advanced study
um decided that he would try and bag the
most famous name in science to put his
brand new institute on the map and uh
and he made einstein an offer and i
think caltech
expected to get him and were surprised
when
they did not especially to you know the
institute for advanced study now is
this extraordinary place with this great
reputation all these people who've been
there
uh but then it was uh it was an empty
field in
in in princeton borrowing quarters on
the on the campus of the university
there
it was nothing it was just starting um
and it was
i think einstein at that point that he'd
been very worldly and very much involved
in
in in you know big city affairs i think
he actually welcomed a chance to get
away from the craziness of europe and go
to a place
that he had his doubts about but that
was he called princeton land of puny
demigods on stilts in a letter shortly
afterwards
but why princeton over uh i think
i think he liked the peace and quiet
i think he liked in some senses the
isolation um i think he was beginning to
really value both an ability to focus on
what he was interested in and
perhaps some remove from a physics
community that was no longer interested
in things that he valued and that
he correctly saw as less and less
interested
in his view of the proper path for
physics going forward
so is it fair to say brian that he was
less
um productive during these
years oh yeah hugely so i mean between
1933 and when he died in 55 he
wrote a lot of papers but the ones that
we really remember there's just a small
handful of them the one that you
referred to earlier his work
that was aimed at trying to use
the math of quantum mechanics to destroy
quantum mechanics in some sense
but ultimately it didn't turn out that
way in fact he just
revealed and emphasized one of the total
strange features of quantum mechanics
called quantum entanglement
that's 1935. he wrote some other
interesting
paper in 1939 but throughout it all
he was in search of one real prize which
was the unified theory
and this was a direct extension
of everything that he had achieved as a
young man so remember back in 1905 he's
in the patent office he
is an outsider to the establishment
comes up with these new
ideas of special relativity which turn
everything on its head
and then he gets brought in to the
establishment but he's still a very
independent thinker
ten years later the general theory of
relativity you know an amazing discovery
but now he's like smack in the middle of
of science in the traditional
established sense and it's as if
at that point he is
trying to use all of the techniques and
methods
that served him so powerfully well as a
young man
and he just beats on that same approach
over and over again
but the methods were no longer suited to
the next task
the next task required other ideas
and that's why he kind of doesn't make
any progress really toward the unified
theory so i want to go back to the idea
of genius
did he just was he a comet who who
flared out after
201 1905 i mean was he was this because
his brain
i mean he he overdid it and now he's
resting
was it because what
or i mean does the human brain only have
a certain capacity and he used it up and
then some
what what well i i think scientists such
as einstein and
mathematicians in particular they do
have a trajectory and they tend to
have their greatest achievements earlier
in life why
um flexibility maybe or
it's hard to absorb the newer ideas we
like to think none of that's really true
einstein einstein starts doing
interesting publishing and
he actually published his first papers
in 1904 and they were once dismissed as
completely inconsequential papers
they're not they're they're building
blocks for some of what he's going to do
next
and he keeps on doing really first class
you know
nobel prize or near nobel prize quality
work until 1925
when he is 46.
is that right something like that born
in 1879 yes sir
so he has um a 20-year
run of producing you know bleeding edge
stuff across again as brian said right
in the outside you know his last papers
were about statistics and statistics in
a very deep and important way
that really were i mean he he not he
knocked right on the door
of the you know modern quantum
mechanical theory with that stuff in
1925
it's amazing stuff he made a prediction
that was only
actually developed in those papers
that's where he predicts bose einstein
condensate which is this new state of
matter that happens when you get things
very cold
and you know so quantum scale objects
stop behaving like quantum objects they
become macroscopic objects and these are
amazing
weird difficult ideas they involve
leaps from mathematics to you know
imagination
about you know actual physical intuition
i mean it's extraordinary stuff
20 years after he did the stuff that
we're we started out talking out
about so it's not as if you know he
flamed out after one great year
he had a run that was better than almost
any
person can hold okay granted granted
but does it still run out i mean i guess
that's the
question about genius i mean it it it
doesn't
does it peter out or or you know did he
finally
launch upon a problem that was insoluble
which is the theory of everything
i mean there's people you know whitton
at the institute you know they're still
trying to suss that out with
you know enviro unverifiable results so
he may have finally bitten off more than
he could chew
no shame in that but he did not you know
to his dying day he was not able to come
up with a unification
of strong force weak force
electromagnetism and gravity was not
going to happen
and he was sort of marginalized because
of the quantum mechanics story he never
could accept it he would get into fights
with bohr
and he'd say and he would say this is an
incomplete
description of reality he just never
could deal with quantum mechanics
and they marginalized him so i don't
know if that's
you know you're running out of neuronal
steam or you're picking fights that you
can't win
on the other hand he becomes like this
folk hero legend
symbol right while he may not have been
as productive and i think we all have to
agree he wasn't as productive
right as he was in his early life he
became this iconic figure
i love show the picture of the sandals i
love this picture
um he's where he got the picture
there it's coming um there we go
yeah yeah okay who can't love this guy
those are actually now we know excellent
research that he is actually
wearing sandals that are a woman's size
11
as confirmed by the man who sold them to
him david rothman in southwark county
long island we had to get that in
but this is actually a great kind of a
tradition among
physicists that what you look like on
the weekend yeah right and there you go
nice nice nice
yeah good good take that down now
thank you oh
there's so much your shoes young lady
right over there
yeah hi tracy um there is so much
folklore around einstein i mean i love
the clipping from the new york times
where he says he's incapable of doing
his taxes because they're so
complicated i mean i mean
and he cultivates that too i mean you've
studied this more than i but he's well
aware
of uh you go yeah there you go you know
he's welcome
and uh i think he enjoyed starting to
starting the myth going forward yeah
so he he he kind of enjoys being a
celebrity
right i mean he's no kim kardashian but
he's enjoying being a celebrity
well he didn't do signing tours but you
know there's lots of kids in princeton
probably still alive who he helped with
their math problems he was this kind of
avuncular as you say genial person i
mean i i guess he did you know that's
obviously charlie chaplin and he would
take an occasional star turn
but you know he never really left
princeton from 33 for a prolonged period
of time
yeah that's the the premiere of city
lights and uh there's this
famous a probably apocryphal story
where you know einstein and chaplin come
in on the red carpet and there's this
crowd
cheering and einstein says to
chaplain allegedly what does it all mean
and chaplin says
nothing which again is you know that
that story itself is part of the
cultivation of the myth the other
worldly man
um yeah he he did like being a celebrity
but he also
used it i mean he actually made
practical use of it
one time when he came to america he made
reporters who wanted to interview him
make a small donation to um to help with
one of his causes i think it was
displaced refugees um he obviously used
his celebrity to do all kinds of
attempts of political activism including
writing to roosevelt
that it was time for the u.s to start
paying attention to uh the atomic bomb
so i mean he would he he was willing to
be
famous if it helped him advance causes
that he believed in
including that one so do you think it's
possible he
was distracted from the science or not
i don't think we're going to know for
for sure he certainly was on on the
larger arena in terms of you know being
asked to be the uh
prime minister of israel or the leader
of israel at one point that which he
turned down
he did to his to his everlasting credit
and he had a wisdom
and ben gurion said asked ben gurion
invited me president and then
said to an adviser what do we do if he
accepts right
but you know um he he was a private
intellectual
um a lot of his work could be done by
himself
in in his office and he lived in a world
of ideas
i think the thing that's often
underplayed is the years at the
institute for advanced study one one of
his boon companions there was
curt goodell you know the uh the author
of the the
he framed the incompleteness theorem so
you've got you've got einstein with
relativity gerdell with incompleteness
the only one you're missing is
heisenberg with uncertainty if you're
talking about three kind of
cardinal cutting edge conceptions that
characterize the 20th century
so god knows what kind of conversations
he would have and there's pictures of
him and
gerdell going towards mercer street for
lunch and
i imagine he got his intellectual rocks
off with some of those conversations
i i want to talk about it i want you to
talk about his brain and what and what
we know
actually physically what what do we know
from einstein so you need to tell the
story about
what actually happened for those in the
audience too well you know
cut me off because it's a long story but
it begins the brain the story of the
brain begins when he
passes away on april 18 1955
he knew he was going to die uh he'd
actually been living on borrowed time
he had an aortic aneurysm abdominal
aortic aneurysm and you didn't have much
you could do for it in those days he'd
actually had an operation several years
earlier
they would wrap cellophane around it
with the idea that you'd scar down to
keep it from rupturing
but it didn't hold and it came back and
he knew it and so april 18th 1955
he passes away utters a few words of
indecipherable
german we don't know what he said and
the the body is taken down for the
autopsy the routine postmortem
determined the cause of death
and had he left instructions no nothing
nothing there is nothing in the will
about the disposal of his body
somehow it was known that he wanted to
be cremated that that was known
um april 19th which that thing you just
showed was the next day in the new york
times
his family basically his son hans albert
and his executor otto nathan read that
the brain has been kept
and they're going what nothing mentioned
in in the will but that was like not on
the script
and they go to the pathologist thomas
harvey a guy in his 40s who's the
only chief pathologist at this little
medical
little hospital princeton hospital and
harvey
pitches the the pitch of his life and he
says we're never going to get another
chance like this
let let me study the brain and hans
albert goes for it and so does auto
nathan so what do we know
what do we know as a result of of
preserving i mean i can show you some
pictures
let's do that okay let me tell you what
we don't know
we'll start okay okay it's not a bigger
brain it's not a bigger brain okay
that's it's not bigger it's not bigger
it's 1230 grams
not a big brain so if you're into the
bigger is better doesn't work for
central nervous system but the
architecture
is different and rather than me say well
this squiggle goes there and that's
let me show you okay all right so let me
just
okay let me just orient you real quick
cut me off if this goes too long
okay frontal lobe that's the back of
your brain this is his right
this is his right hemisphere the right
there is a split
the hemispheric split inner hemispheric
split okay
just the highlight the game highlights
on this okay here's your front
frontal lobes one two three four
four frontal gyri the great great great
majority we don't have
of us have three he had four that is
a serious anomaly how do we know that
because there are standard atlases of
brain anatomy ono and connolly
and again i am stealing from my
colleague dean faulk who's the real
anatomist in this
and she poured over this brain but in
any event that is not standard issue
that frontal lobe
okay so one more makes a big difference
okay got it yeah i mean that's the
you know if i say anything more than
that you're going to say well you're a
phrenologist
and i'm not all i can tell you is the
brain is different and the guy was a
genius
um that's all i can tell you that's not
going to get you an a on the final okay
no i know i'd love to see okay all right
there's your cortical knob the violin
part see that looks
can you go back one yep ah give me a
little more back
one okay yeah see that thing cortical
knob that's on the right hemisphere so
that's
presumably what's the knob well well
call it an omega sign
call it a kink they just the literature
calls it a knob you see it's that little
i'll show you better but that little
u-turn there yeah that's not standard
issue and there's stuff we don't even
know
this is uh this is a diagonal uh sulcus
here there's no name i talked to dean
faulk emailed her this morning
there's no name for that thing it's not
described in regular anatomy
anatomy textbooks so he's got a lot of
variant anatomy next slide
okay this is if you cut the brain in
half okay all right
so that's the frontal lobe that's your
occipital lobe
that's your corpus callosum that's the
fiber pathway that connects up your
right hemisphere with your left
hemisphere
we didn't do it we recovered this
photograph these photographs have been
lost for half a century we recovered
these photographs
and now we start to analyze them and
dr men weigh men out in east china
normal
sees the photo goes wow look at that
corpus callosum sets up a computer
program
he's got a larger than normal corpus
callosum large not
age lot for age-matched guys but for
even
young people he's got greater internal
wiring anatomically with his corpus
callosum
which opens up a whole other can of
worms where you're not really talking
about the stuff on your surface on your
cortex you're talking about the internal
wiring and he obviously this is a sign
of greater white matter internal wiring
or if you want to use the sexy new terms
connectome he has a a different
connectome
that's the major finding on that so his
brain really was different than
everybody else's no doubt about it
they don't publish this stuff in brain
unless you can prove that it's
anatomically
very different so does but does the
brain change over time with use
i mean did he have an extraordinary
brain and then i mean obviously the
brain by itself
right the answer is yes it does change
but you don't see it like this
you don't i mean so this wasn't just
because he worked really really hard
i mean we don't know first place i got
no cohort of genius brains we're never
going to get newton we're never going to
get galileo we're not going to get
touring so we don't have comparisons we
have some smart people but we don't have
einstein quality brains to compare to
that's a problem with this but if your
question is does your brain
change with experience yeah that's how
eric kandel got his nobel prize only he
wasn't working with human brains he was
working with
sea slugs and he showed that every time
you
shocked these things that they would
rewire their nervous system
now the question is if you multiply that
by 85 billion neurons which you and i
all have
could you actually change the surface of
the brain i
doubt it but i don't know you know you'd
have to have
you know serial neural imaging looking
at cortical anatomy
and you know dean and i we basically
this is unfundable stuff it's really
cool but i don't know if there's someone
out there who could actually trace
neuroimaging to show you the core you
know development of your of your gyri
and sulci your cortical anatomy
it's not out there yet if someone's
doing it jb asked about the number of
convolutions i don't even know what that
is but thank you jb
in the context of what are the physical
manifestations of intelligence
in the human brain the size he asked
about and the number what the number of
convolutions is that the
squiggly thing yeah right exactly we
call them gyrai
and sulci but you know it's it's not so
much that it's a quantitative thing that
you know i can show you that he's got
different variant arrangement of
these guys yeah okay this is his left
hemisphere
and again um different stuff this is
uh this is your motor motor strip
that's your sensory strip that's where
that would represent your face we know
that because
from cortical stimulation things uh
experiments penfield since the 50s
that uh that is a very large elaborate
motor and somatosensory cortex around
the face and mouth
but you can't translate that into
special relativity or quantum theory
um he's got this is close this is
broca's area
speech area remember it's your left
hemisphere very very
additional you can't really measure that
with a number but he's got very involved
cortical development there
you don't normally see that so that's a
variant
here one of the things we got into in
looking at the old literature was
the reason we were able to come out with
this i mean people have had these
photographs but no one had
dozens of these photographs and the
thing with the brain is you got to have
it from different angles
or you're going to miss a lot of nuances
of the anatomy and to show you what i
mean
they the the original articles in the
90s about they said that this was a
continuous
groove sulcus and it's not
that is actually an interruption that's
an anatomical difference that's a hidden
gyrus
now if you take that photograph from
another angle which other investigators
they only had five photographs to work
with
you don't see it it's like a slot canyon
if you're off on the side
you can't see what's the bottom of that
canyon until you get over it and when
you get that right shot you see
where did that come from that's a whole
different gyrus hidden
in that sulcus no one knew about it
because those photographs had been
stashed
in in thomas harvey's cellar for a half
century
so there's a lot of little things like
that that tells you the brain is
different i just can't point to you and
say well this is why
he was a good violent well maybe a
violin player maybe i could tell you
that
but i can't tell you why he could do
guntonica experiments i can't tell you
why
he could learn tensor calculus to figure
out the theory of general relativity
right why he becomes why this brain
leads to him becoming the physicist of
the ages i mean you can't just
we don't know i mean if you put that
brain in front of me uh you couldn't or
brains like that you couldn't tell that
the guy was you'd say well that's an
interesting brain
part of the thing is this is kind of a
lost art you know cortical anatomy is
this is a this study was a very
interesting dirt
detour off the main road of neuroscience
but it really is a detour
thomas harvey the guy who did the
original study and chopped the brain
into 240 sections and you'll see
pictures of that
he didn't bet on this he took the
photograph because he was an obsessive
good pathologist
but this is where he thought the money
was in terms of making a finding
you you basically cut the brain at 240
uh sections and then you make slides
from that and you look at the
microscopic anatomy that's what harvey
thought
if i can look at the microscopic anatomy
i can figure out what makes albert
einstein and
tick 30 years went by before the first
paper came out in 1985 marion diamond
and she said well maybe there's a few
more glial cells and neurons
and they're still brooding that about
but 30 years and he sent this brain
around
to the great neuroscientist pathologist
such as they were in america no one
could find anything positive
diamond does it in 85 10 years later
there's one more paper on histology
so everyone harvey included was focusing
it's got to be microscopic
and we just happened to get these
photographs and said well let's just for
the hell of it look at the surface of
the brain and in point of fact it was
dramatically different
big surprise well i learned something i
don't know about the rest
wow okay so it's not size we got that
yeah
but the physical structure is very
different than a regular brain
absolutely okay thank you okay that but
i mean that's fascinating and chopping
it up
really wasn't the key to it it was
looking at this the whole surface of it
not the keynote i mean if you're saying
if you say well lapor
come on well you know where do we go
next
can we look at the wiring can we look at
the connect dome
and now you're going to have to
resection those cubes they're embedded
in plastic look at them under the
microscope and measure the myelin length
and the of the neuronal fibers maybe
maybe you're going to get something out
of it i mean
the cortical anatomy i think we've run
the table on that i just
you know it's a very interesting idea
though that the brain itself doesn't
make the genius maybe it's a necessary
and sufficient condition but
then he has to do something i mean right
right i mean
yeah i mean it could be a necessary
condition but not
no not sufficient yeah i mean right all
the other things that were going on in
his life
i mean the things that made him look at
the establishment and be willing to
challenge it i mean the traditional
graduate student goes up the ranks and
wants to please
their advisor wants to please other
faculty because they know they're going
to
give the recommendations for the next
stage of their career and einstein just
didn't care about that and i'm sure you
can trace that
psychological mindset to earlier place
in his life people have done that
but i think that experience and that
frame of mind
was as potentially important as the
extra thingamabob that when found inside
of his brain
that's what i call it too yeah i just
want to bear down on this point a little
bit though i mean there's the father of
quantum mechanics who find who turns his
back on it
right um
to those who have said the last 30 years
of his life not as product not that they
were unproductive but
not as productive i mean where where do
you come out in this
this conversation how great was his
contribution in your opinion
after his arrival in princeton uh i
guess the answer is similar to tom's
that in
in the grand scheme of things it just
doesn't matter what he did
by 1915 was
so extraordinary that you
you there's nothing that could possibly
tarnish
his standing in the in the in the
scientific world
now it is the case that he had a
singular goal and a singular focus
and in fact he thought repeatedly that
he had found the unified he published
many papers
on the unified theory paper after paper
after paper
ultimately he'd say ah that's not quite
right but i have the
new idea and he'd publish that one and
this cycle went on for
for decades and it ultimately
was not influential but he
said in other words when we do our work
today day to day
there's almost nothing that we do that
doesn't
come to us from einstein every
calculation that we do
relies upon ideas in relativity either
the specialty or the general theory and
every calculation that we do in quantum
mechanics ultimately goes back to the
very ideas that were in the
photoelectric effect so
there's there's there's his influence is
so spectacular and deep
so tom was he happy with himself did he
feel he'd done a good job how did he
feel
was he frustrated or did you know i
asked him i'll streep once if she if she
when
she was having a bad day if she thought
well i am the greatest actress of my
generation she said do i look crazy to
you
so how did how did einstein feel about
his
accomplishment was he i don't think i
mean i i don't think most of us
most days take stock of our lives and
say okay i've i'm i am
you know i'm i'm my life is a success my
life is has value or not
um einstein you know einstein did
calculations on the last day of his life
right he kept working and i think that's
you know he he he did say once that
he knew that most of his colleagues
thought he'd gone crazy there was
something he put it slightly differently
slightly less
less harshly but he said but it's okay
i've you know i've earned the right
to be as you know stubborn and as
focused on what i'm interested in
and so to that extent yeah he knew he he
was albert einstein he had done his
he'd done good stuff and if he thought
something was important it was okay to
pursue it
but you know going to the gym did you
see it as a failure
not being able to find a unifying theory
of everything yeah i mean yes
he he yes and no he in the 50s
a few times said you know it's getting
clear that i am not going to solve this
problem
but he also said i'm not going to stop
working on it this is the problem i'm
interested in
you know to the general question of you
know what can we say
from a singular you know one data point
einstein
about the nature of genius one thing is
there is
you know people are not geniuses out of
context
einstein for decades had a series of
problems
for which his experience his approach
his aesthetics just his
you know what seemed to him beautiful
matched the problems
that were in front of them and when you
had the quantum mechanical revolution
um two things happened one is that was
no longer the cases didn't meet his his
aesthetic
interest and also to a certain extent
his approach you know leave aside his
taste his approach was no longer
really suited for that you know the ways
he thought of it and this is you know i
want to sort of toss to brian
but you know his gedonkan experiments
his ability to construct
very simple visual pictures that would
allow him to absorb
abstract down to the the critical
problem all that that's
from what i understand from talking to
people like brian
is really difficult as in impossible to
do in the counter-intuitive world of
quantum mechanics
so the genius that einstein was was a
great genius
for that transitional period in the
early 20th century and not so much
after do you know that's true i mean and
i think that if you trace the roots of
that
you can find it starting to occur
in the last couple months as he's trying
to get the general theory of relativity
so he had this uncanny ability from
sort of 1905 up to call it you know
1912 1913 where he would come up with
these thought experiments and think them
through and
have these visualizations but that
in 1912 13 leads him down
the wrong trajectory so he spends two
years roughly
1912 to 1914 on an approach to the
general theory that ultimately fails
and at that point he takes a step back
and says let me just
let the math take me to the promised
land let me just use romanian geometry
tensor calculus
and i'm going to follow it where it
takes me
and it leads him to the answer and i
think from that
he kind of changed his approach where
now mathematics
was going to be what would lead him
forward and a very particular kind
of mathematics a mathematics that's much
better suited
to the classical world that's not suited
to the quantum world
and i think that is why he goes like
this
after sort of 1915 1919
following that same kind of mathematical
trajectory that had been so effective
but it no longer was the right approach
so even regardless of the
fold inside his brain he had
a style he had a belief in the way
forward
but it turned out not to be the right
one or not yet who knows
we don't have the answers yet maybe a
generation or two for now we'll look
back at einstein say
he was actually following the right
trajectory but he just didn't get there
that could still happen so we have some
great questions from the audience so
let's try to get through a few of these
in our remaining moments
um why do you think einstein never came
across string theory during his quest
for a theory of everything
i just wasn't smart enough you know
next which is missing a few folds they
believe
right which
um which of his discoveries did einstein
like or enjoy the most great question
what was this which of his his
discoveries his theories did he
personally enjoy
or celebrate himself the most
right after november 1915 he wrote a
letter to
um i think was arthur arnold summerfeld
great physicist said study these
equations well they are the greatest
accomplishment of my
life as against that he also said i've
spent
much much more time through my uh
through my life thinking about the
problem of the quantum than
anything else yes so you know maybe he's
like a parent
all his children are beautiful
all right this is another great question
do you believe that going through and
learning to overcome adversity is key to
accomplishing the feats that einstein
and other geniuses did
and in in his life their lives is there
a neuroscience
to support this well it's hard to reduce
it to the neuroscience but
you know when you get back to general
relativity
you know i think i think einstein was a
great intuitive physicist i mean
you know with the gentile godokan
experiments you know i'm in a box and
it's accelerating and
is that gravity or is that acceleration
but it's at some point
he would take the bit between his teeth
and say i gotta i gotta learn the math
and he didn't like math he he he felt to
purely
um concentrate on math would take him
places he didn't want to go
but in order to justify those physical
intuitions
godokan experiments then he would learn
rhymanian then he would learn tensor
calculus
um so that that that's kind of like
if you're a research guy you you got to
get a whole new set of skills you got to
build up your expert knowledge system
and you basically
leave one thing and you have a whole new
skill that you have to adopt and that
gets harder i know it gets harder for me
when you get older
to learn a new skill set but he could do
it he could do it
at a certain point maybe he couldn't do
it but he had a great run
what do you compare him to isaac newton
you know
after newton you know when he left
cambridge when the plague was coming
through and he goes off in the
countryside and does
uh calculus or principia what did he do
afterwards he ran a mint he wrote things
about alchemy he had
theological interests but you know
it's just hard to to to have peak
performance for every
clicking off those decades so no shame
in that
and the hair um the hair
this is a little off great hair too by
the way
maybe maybe we're finding a theory of
everything
okay um this is a little off topic but i
think brian this is a question you might
well enjoy uh what will be the next
significant breakthrough
in physics well i think the big
breakthrough is still finding
einstein's dream of this unified theory
but a little bit more
specifically einstein gave us a new
picture of space and time
special relativity we learned that they
can sort of meld together
that motion through space affects the
passage of time in general relatively we
learn that
matter warps and curves space and time
in the surface of gravity
but there hasn't really been the next
step in that progression
which is to address the question what
actually are
space and time are they fundamental
constructs
or could it be the case that space and
time are themselves made of something
finer right i mean you look at any piece
of matter
it's made of ingredients molecules atoms
sub-atomic particles could it be the
case
that space and time also are subject to
that
kind of structure that there are atoms
of space
atoms of time what would those be what
would describe them
how do we describe a realm in which
familiar time
has not yet emerged because those
constituents haven't arranged themselves
in a manner that yields
space and time as we experience it so i
think really
getting to the bottom of what space and
time
are is the next big step
i think that's pretty good i was going
to say that
so i do think um
listening to you listening to all three
of you i mean in a way
there's also there's a there's a sort of
science a purity of science but there's
also a philosophy
that goes along with some of this
einstein referenced god a good deal
let's talk for a moment before we
conclude about einstein's vision of
of religion and the greater and the
in the greater whole and how and how
his ideas connected to that
okay um einstein
was an extremely clever man as well as
being a deeply smart man
and he used god talk in
a variety of metaphoric ways he himself
said that his god was spinoza's god the
abstract ordering of the universe
he was not a person of traditional faith
uh you know you know in one of the in
any of the revealed
religions judaism as his tradition uh he
didn't
you know the the the um
the traditional view of god as some
supernatural being
acting in sp acting in time that was
nonsense to him and he could be very
harsh in
private describing this nonsense um you
know he went to
to palestine in as as then
in the early 20s
saw traditional orthodox jews praying at
the
the wailing wall and was contemptuous of
them i mean his private writing about it
is just you know it's it's really
these people are are crazy they're lost
in time this kind of thing
um at the same time he really did feel a
very strong
sense that the fact that the universe
was ordered and it that order was
accessible to human reason
was a deeply beautiful deeply mysterious
fact of life right and he was perfectly
willing to talk about that in terms that
were congenial
uh to broader discussions about religion
uh
so he used god in lots of different
settings
he's the word god in the concept of some
super ordering power
uh in all kinds of ways he could again
be satirical he didn't
believe in a design no he did not
believe in the god of abraham isaac and
jacob
or of jesus or any you know he that god
was not part of einstein's lexicon
except to declare that it didn't exist
when a friend of his seriously no friend
and to you i mean listen let's be honest
a lot of the a lot of his best-known
quotes have to do though with
you know god well yeah but god in that
metaphoric sense or god in that sense to
make his philosophical ideas i think
palatable to wide audiences
he was a spiritual person he believed in
things that were larger than himself
but the thing that he believed in that
was larger than himself was nature and
the accessibility of nature's
organization
to human uh intellect and and you know
that was extremely powerful for him it
moved him he saw himself as
as you know seeking to be at one with
nature and occasionally having these
spiritual or transcended experiences
when he felt that he wrote that in
one of his travel diaries contemplating
the ocean this kind of thing
but you know attempting to shoehorn him
into some picture of
the scientist who really secretly
believes in a traditional sense no
that's not einstein
so let's conclude by asking the question
we're going to do a little
moment at the end about the 100th
anniversary of general relativity but
before we conclude
genius was he i guess we can all agree
about that
yes but why why do you feel brian let's
start with you
well i think the obvious answer that we
would all give
but maybe i'll be proven wrong in 30
seconds
is that it was this remarkable union of
all the things that we're talking about
right so
clearly there's something different
about his brain presumably that had some
role because the brain is where
presumably all this stuff happened but
it was this
wonderful confluence of his own personal
history
of the kinds of open problems that were
available
for progress at that time right so
it was the right moment for thinking
about space
and time and light maxwell had given us
the equations of electricity and
magnetism in the
1880s right so this is when einstein
is born and starting to think about
things so he's there at the right moment
he's got the right physical structure
and he's got the right
attitude he's got this perspective that
i don't care what anybody thinks i'm
just gonna go forward and
understand the world so you put all
those three together and
at least for part of the time you see
what emerges
right well he certainly was an
incredibly hard worker he had the
infinite capacity to take pains i agree
though that
um he was a little bit of a lone wolf
and that may have helped him in the
sense that when you're in that patent
office making your living looking at
at inventions you can't get to the
university library because the hours
were such that
he basically was a lot of his thinking
was
his own thinking and he was not in at
that point in the academic establishment
and if you look at those original
manuscripts in 1905 they're all
handwritten
out and there's not a lot of references
think of an academic submitting any kind
of paper with no references or
few references just doesn't happen that
you the referees would eat you alive
but einstein just the strength of his
ideas and his independent thinking
untrembled upon by
external influences you know maybe that
did give him the focus to to come up
with these
that anis mirabilis in in 1905.
but one thing i would say genius it's
not
you know everyone it's not homogeneous i
mean there are all sorts of geniuses i
mean
you know there's a guy on the basketball
court has got ball smarts
you got social geniuses we call them
politicians
you know okay so i mean he was
you know a physical genius he was in
physics a physics genius
i'm not going to tell you what i see on
those photographs really explains that
um he wasn't a great mathematician but
he learned enough math
to do to take his strong suit which is
physics
and and couch it in in mathematical
terms
and make it demonstrable to the public
to the scientific public
tom wind it up for us well i think i
mean i agree with what's been said
uh by both brian and fred um if the word
genius has any meaning at all einstein
has to be
on that list um he was a genius
uh in his you know the measure of it is
his accomplishments
but i guess from where i said the point
i keep
coming back to is that the particulars
of history matter
you know if einstein had been born in
germany
before 1900 before 1800
he would have been before the napoleonic
you know emancipation
he would as a you know a jewish kid
raised by
a jewish family from the villages
of you know south germany would never
have come close to the education he
needed
to make the first step in any scientific
career
so you know i missed by 100 years if
einstein had been born
30 years later he would have been a very
bright good scientist
but he would have missed some of the
window of opportunity that he
he you know went through so so eagerly
um and he might have gotten caught up
you know
the particulars of history uh matter
enormously to the ability
of people with the capacity for genius
to actually exercise it you know genius
is not
an in is not simply an internal
characteristic
of brain and smarts and talent and all
that
it's those combined with circumstance
and the circumstances are social
we have geniuses because we have
societies that are congenial to them at
that time
fascinating well all of you i've learned
so much and
thank you all really so much
i want to thank all of you for being
such a great audience and it is the
100th anniversary of relativity so
what's the
science world science the science
festival will have that as a theme this
year so if you enjoy this conversation
look for a variety of programs that will
explore general relativity
this may so keep your eye out for thanks
thanks very
was
much